i have a second thing yeah go ahead yo
please okay i'm so excited for this okay
i got asked to get off a plane
leaving austin texas i i heard about
that and i was like oh you texted me
yeah you texted me but like so i love
that you just see you're unlike any
other guest i have a guest like i just
interviewed and they're like i don't
want to talk about that and you talk
about everything you're an open book and
that's why i think it's it's healthy and
people like you uh thank you i wanted to
have just a slight runway here to be
able to
talk about this because
what happened was and it's very very
simple all right uh i had
too many drinks and i had too many
drinks in a public place right
and i got on a plane
and
the reason that i want to talk about it
is and we'll get to it eventually this
will all make sense
is
i was pissed off about something else
that had nothing to do with cass my wife
right and i picked a fight just i picked
a fight because i wanted to be
loud
and upset
and it was a fight
as in like it was not an argument in
order to have an argument
two people two people have to be right
engaged my wife said one thing the
entire time
which was if you don't lower your voice
they're gonna ask you to get off the
plane that's the only thing that she
said the entire time what are you doing
the whole time i was i can't even you
know honestly i can't even remember what
i was upset about which was indicative
of two things a
handle your liquor i had too many drinks
right and
and b it clearly wasn't important i was
just upset and wanted to be
upset and sure enough after she said
this
a guy came by and he said sir you have
to keep your voice down please is that a
random guy or a flight attendant no uh
it wasn't a flight attendant it was the
guy that the flight attendant had
clearly called so obviously cass was 100
right here right i was being loud i was
probably dropping a few f-bombs i've got
the noise canceled this is not an excuse
i'm not here to make i'm not here to
make excuses
and you're being louder
but yeah and i don't even want to i
don't want to smile while i'm telling
this story because it i'm actually
frankly like deeply ashamed of it
um
but
i got asked i was quiet for 10 minutes
the guy came back clearly i had made
somebody uncomfortable and someone had
said something
and they just made the decision you got
to get off the plane so i got off the
plane i booked on the next flight
i went from did you sober up for the
next flight
yeah i sure did
why because i was sitting in row 17 in
the middle seat as a as opposed to i
mean i want to get home right
but uh
but then i found out that it was going
to come out on tmz and
and when i found that out and the reason
i want to bring it up is because i
talked about it and in my one thing that
i said about it on the internet i
referred to it as an argument between my
wife and i
and it wasn't it was not an argument it
was just being loud it was me this is a
hundred percent my fault like
i i feel like i went
the better part of 10 years without you
know being an [ __ ] in public
i was an [ __ ] in public was she how
pissed was cass super pissed and she
should be pissed and she was frankly uh
even more pissed when i
said argument as opposed to
pick a fight
and i sent that tweet at like four
o'clock in the morning because i woke up
to a text from my buddy in toronto that
just said are you okay and i went oh my
god it's out it's out
and they used a shitty old photo from
like seven years ago and the whole the
whole thing sucks it's it's it's it's
it's it's really
it's really really shameful and it makes
you kind of look look in the mirror and
and i just realized a couple of things
don't
uh
you know if people are going to
recognize you
uh you know don't necessarily drink in a
public place but more importantly don't
drink in a public place if you can't
handle your [ __ ] but i've never known
you to be someone who can't handle their
alcohol or gets a little uh out there
with it well on occasion
that is what happens but i mean don't do
it on a plane you [ __ ] loser
and and that was it and you texted me on
the on the b side of it so i mean that's
it that's the whole story but
you know the the the
the long tail the b side of it is
the [ __ ] phone calls that you have to
make apologizing because
the story hits and you know
i've got to call my mom and i've got a
call what happened what were you doing
are you okay are you okay buddy it's
like yes i'm okay let me ask you this
did you resist them taking off the plane
no and that's the scariest part for me
the scariest part is that i was
inebriated
i was upset
and it would have been very easy when
the gentleman came up and said
you collect your things let's talk at
the top of the entrance way and i said
to him
please do not make me get off this plane
i was focused in i was staring out the
window i wasn't going to say a word for
the next two and a half hours
and he said we'll collect your things
we'll talk about at the top of the
entrance way and i went
okay
but you were tempted to be a little bit
well what if i if i if i just casually
flippantly
not being in
sound mind and body
if i offer like a quick passive [ __ ] off
and all of a sudden i'm in i'm in
bracelets yeah
i i might i mean maybe i destroyed my
entire life my entire career so i think
ultimately
very ashamed of it trying to make amends
for it specifically with with my wife
she's forgiven you at this point this
has been a while i mean i mean it's a
work and it's a work in progress it was
it's not the best right i mean you can
you can work through things but that
doesn't mean they didn't happen
right what kind of conversations do you
have at home do you have conversations
like cass saying things like i don't
like seeing you like that i don't want
to be around that
well i mean not
not since not since that point right
but i don't know i i just
you know this is a weird experience that
we all live in where
people just sort of give you whatever
you want
and
and occasionally that leads to just not
setting appropriate boundaries in your
own in your own life so we're having
conversations about that about just
basic stuff and you know it's it's a
good thing but i'm it's a good thing
that we have those conversations i'm
just i'm just happy that i didn't
give the tertiary passive
[ __ ] off
because then i'm in a then i'm in jail
in austin
you